Alright. Hey guys, sorry. Hey, we're here now. Peter. Simon, Simon,
how are you man? I'm doing well and yourself? Good.
Okay. Uh, who's who? Um, Peter is a DJ. Peter Rosenberg from hot 97.
Simon Adler is a journalist.
Our Pal Andrew Moran from the New Yorker is also in the room and Robert and I
are in the back.
Good. Well, uh, we have all gathered here today to talk about, uh,
the wonderful world of professional wrestling,
my favorite world.
So yes,
we're going to talk about professional wrestling for the first half of the show.
And we realize there's probably a lot of you out there listening right now who
are like,
seriously guys, there are people like, wait, you're 35 years old.
Do you love wrestling? I get this a lot if I'm tweeting about it a lot,
I get tweets that go, you know, it's fake, right? It's like,
we'll do I write you that when you tweet about your favorite movie,
it's entertainment. The awesome thing about wrestling is,
is that there are these random things that are a little bit real,
and sometimes those moments of real, this can just be like,
oh, [inaudible],
they can change everything.
Oh,
now if you're like me and you grew up in the 80s, a,
you might remember wrestling is like, you know how close versus Andre the giant,
these epic matchups that were kind of great but also sort of ridiculous and
cartoonish? Well, according to Peter Rosenberg,
there was a moment where wrestling started to sort of tinker with reality and a
much more nuanced and a fascinating way. In fact,
you could argue that pro wrestling became re instantiation.
I love the Baroque Movement of the 16th century, but the postmodern twist,
I know people who would, and you're going to meet them.
I'm Jad. I'm Robert. This is Radiolab. Ed. Uh, according to Peter,
this whole thing's where we're going to start.
This whole thing goes back to this moment called the Montreal screw job.
The Montreux screw job was above anything else that had ever happened or that
will ever probably ever happen again because it was odor,
reality transpiring right there in the ring.
I mean it was when real life just came and tore a hole
in the fiction.
That guy you just heard is David Shoemaker.
I write about professional wrestling for Grantland and the guy you're about to
hear is journalists, Simon Adler. He will take the story from here. Okay,
so the moment in question really centers around this one guy named Brett,
they hit man hug.
Brett Hart is seen by many to be the greatest entering performer of all time.
He was one of the good guys. I am
the [inaudible]
business. They call him a baby face. Is that what you call the good guys?
A good guy in wrestling. He's the baby face.
He was my favorite wrestler as a kid. I didn't understand why at the time,
but now I do. It's because he did everything
so well and in that era,
the mid to late eighties when I fell in love with him.
So many guys were just big and hawking and a little bit clumsy,
but Brett did the kind of work that you could show to someone who's,
who's never watched wrestling.
I think they could see the art and I think they could see how it's,
it's like ballet or a million other arts
forms. What he means,
and you can kind of see this when you watch all Brett Hart matches on youtube.
He's gliding through the air, bouncing off the mat, off the ropes,
tell stories brilliantly within the way he executes a map.
So wrestling is scripted, but there's a lot of improv going on there.
The set beats,
he knew how to take those moments and in that Improv make you think,
oh shoot, he's about to lose. And then, yeah.
[inaudible]
he was a natural born wrestler,
you know, his father was a, was a legendary wrestler. His brother, Owen
legendary wrestler
comes from this Canadian wrestling royalty.
Me As a kid growing up,
I had the ability to watch the A or had the fortune to watch these varied
wrestling styles and techniques and stuff.
That's Brett Hart. In an interview in 2000 on fresh air.
And he says it's some of his earliest memories as a kid.
Were these massive dudes showing up to his house and hanging out in his basement
with his dad?
No. Even then my dad was, you know, I'll say 60,
who is teaching them how to be wrestlers,
pull on these old wooly tights.
And then he would wrestle with these guys and he would literally put them in
wrestling, holds these submission wrestling holds, which is his obsession.
And uh,
he would torture these big huge football players for hours and they would scream
literally these high pitched screams. It was terrifying.
I'd be upstairs in the room above it and as I got older,
I would go down and actually venture into the room and sit on the bench and
watch. And uh,
he would sometimes these wrestlers would run out when my dad finally let them
go. They'd actually run out, tear out of the,
out the doorway and out the outside, sometimes in the snow and run out with the,
in their bare feet. And you won't even see them again.
I mean there's a legendary, so many legendary stories about the Hart family,
but you, you know, my favorite among many is, uh,
the bear that lived in their backyard during the summers because at the time
wrestling a bear was a thing that would actually happen from time to time. No,
really. And, uh, Brett tells a story in his book, um, about,
you know, just sitting there and letting the bear lick his toes. I mean,
like this is, this is a life that they, that he lived and he was, he was so in,
it was so ingrained in him.
[inaudible]
so in the early eighties, Brett was working for his dad's company up in Canada.
And while that's going on in Canada, there's this guy, Vince McMahon,
back in the u s who is building kind of this wrestling empire. It basically,
he's buying up all of these small promoters from across the country and
eventually goes up into Canada and buys out breads, dad's company.
I bought it in 1984. They paid them a certain amount of money to stop running,
just to kind of go out of business. And then they took on, uh,
some of his better wrestlers at the time,
which was myself and I had a couple of brother-in-laws.
And shortly thereafter,
Jared,
the WWF comes under fire,
Paul Kogan and other world wrestling federation stars have taken the offensive
against accusations that many have been steroid abuse,
monster mentality,
red to widespread steroid abuse in the world wrestling federation. So
there's this big steroid crisis.
Vince has to deal with all of this litigation and he kind of needs to rebrand
his organization. He needs a new good guy, a new champion, a new baby face.
And he looks to Brett
for that for a couple of reasons. According to David Shoemaker.
One is that he's a traditionalist, sort of a throwback to an earlier time too.
He's not that big. So when you see him, you don't think steroids guys,
definitely, yeah. Roid rage. And so he saw all that in Brett Hart.
So during the 90s, Vince makes Brett a really big star.
Hey Scott,
face of the company. I mean, he was on the Simpsons. He was a really,
really big star. You know,
there are people who criticize Brett for saying he wasn't that fun or he took
himself too seriously, but he was a serious worker.
He took wrestling very seriously for myself.
Really fighting hard to actually survive and come out of it could actually come
out of the wrestling profession someday is as a success rather than a wrestling
tragedy, which is what so many of them turn out.
Okay. So fast forward to 1995, 1996 at the time,
a major rivalry was starting between the WWF that is Vince McMahon's company and
the WCW, um, which was ted Turner's company, Ted Turner,
multichip air.
And one of his big tactics is I'm just going to start buying all of the
wrestlers from the WWF, from Vince McMahon's organization.
So he's offering them more money,
he's offering them longer contracts and he was just like flooding it with money
to steal all the stars from WWF. And then in late 1996,
Brett got an offer. [inaudible] really went in for the kill from WCW.
That was huge. Two point $8 million.
I mean you have to show us the common sense, you know,
first of all you've got to do what's right for your family, but I mean,
how much money do you need?
Sometimes I find myself torn between trying to do the right thing for my family
and at the same time show my loyalties.
It's a clip of Brett talking in a documentary that was being filmed at the time
called wrestling with shadows, which is fantastic.
The filmmaker Paul Jay was nice enough to let us play some clips. In any case,
Brett gets this offer and he's kind of this terrible decision to make because
Vince gave him a lot. You know,
he really gave him his life and initially Brett decides there's no way I'm going
to leave. You know?
I think my relationship with with Vince McMahon was always sort of like a father
and I sort of saw myself. If I left,
it would have been a little bit like leaving my dad,
especially when the chips are down.
He really did see Vince as a father figure. So Brett goes to Vinson,
basically says, convince me to stay. They went back and forth.
There was conversation about him signing a long term deal,
a 20 year deal with WWF. Not for as much money, but for guaranteed security.
Vince said, I can't afford to pay you that.
Just talk to Vince. Nope.
In the documentary, Brett and his wife, they're sitting at a kitchen table.
Are you saying he goes,
nobody wants Brett Hart more than Minspeck man. Why is he letting you go?
He can't afford to compete with Turner. He said,
turners hell bent on trying to put them out of business.
I got to think about everything. I got to think about everything.
Just see what makes sense. Call Eric.
Can we cut this off now for a little while? Okay.
Ultimately it became clear that Brett would have to go take the money.
I can't help but feel really heartbroken and disappointed though,
dawn, that I left this company.
Yeah,
so this really gets to the heart of it. Once Brett decides he's going to leave,
they have to figure out how, how are they going to make his exit?
This is really the pivotal question behind all of this.
Yeah. You know the, it's a very, very delicate situation.
That's Vince Russo and this was sort of his problem to solve because he worked
for Vince McMahon. You know,
you could say I was his right hand man because I was writing the show.
He was part of the team that scripted. Who would win, who would lose,
how it would happen, you know, I mean, I was, you know,
literally putting this show on paper, oh, you know, once a week. Wait,
why is this a hard question? I mean, can you just pick up and leave? Well,
because he's the champion. He has the belt, the physical belt,
the giant golden like belt buckle thing and that belt is the symbol of the
company and everybody in it, everybody working behind the scenes,
everybody who was trying to support their family,
that belt was a representation of all that.
That the worst thing that could happen is your champion walking away with the
belt, driven up to the new company,
holding up the championship from the old company where they could just defile it
if they wanted to. That was not an option for Vince McMahon.
This isn't a perfect comparison,
but the closest thing I've come up to in my mind is it would be like Lebron
James quitting his contract with Nike and then showing up in an commercial and
taking a piss into a pair of Nike's. So you know, Vince,
at the end of the day, he just had to get that belt off of bread.
So their initial thought, their first plan was probably the simplest option.
There was a match coming up, this big event, a paper view event in Montreal,
Brett being the champion of the company,
he should just lose to the number two guy in the company, Shawn Michaels.
Vince loved Sean. I mean really thought Sean was a mega star,
which he was right about. Clearly Sean was next in line.
So they pitched this idea to Brett and Brett was like, I can't do that.
Okay. For one, he thinks Sean is an idiot.
It's got this premadonna personality. I mean,
he thinks he's better than everyone else and is simply very arrogant.
And I'm noxious about him
cause he was, he was a showman. He would hump the ring,
just like do ridiculous things and like to be
Brett. Shaun was the triumph of style over substance. Also,
you're asking Brett to wrap up his career in the WWE with a loss in Montreal in
Canada where he is a national hero.
I described the events.
I'd just assume blow my brains out would be the same what you're asking me to do
from a character standpoint, that's what I would be doing. Brett, the hit man.
Hardwood. Blow his brains out.
Yeah.
Oh, the whole thing's been hard. Okay.
Day of the match.
Still nothing has been decided as to how the match is going to end.
Brett is backstage and eventually he goes to Vince to have a conversation.
Right.
I gotta just talk the documentary crews filming all of this and at this point
Vince says, no, I don't want any cameras in here. Get those Outta here.
And so Brett actually ends up wearing a wire to document the conversation that's
about to happen.
I never ever want to leave here with any kind of bad feeling,
but this week has been a bad week for me. I feel kind of betrayed a little bit.
Well, I go to a little bit, and again I'll,
we're talking about really is check turnaround.
That's what's coming between you and me and that's all.
I can't tell you how appreciative I will always be for everything you've done.
I didn't want to leave with any problems and I actually didn't want to leave it
all and then it's a point where there was no other choice but to go the way this
whole thing has been depicted.
It's really hard for me as a hero here to come up short this weekend.
What would you want to do today then? I'm opening a new,
I think what I'd like to do is get through today.
I think tomorrow I should just go in and do my,
so Brett suggests that this ends in disqualification, right?
Usually what that means is something called a laws or whatever you want.
Typically in a Shmata,
the ring is just flooded with a bunch of wrestlers and chaos into the referee
usually is thrown out of the ring
and it ends in some sort of draw.
Brett would then appear on Monday night raw the next day and turn over the belt.
That is what he planned on doing too.
That way he could turn over the belt but not lose. Exactly.
And eventually Vince says, okay, fine.
I'm anyway,
like I said before on the term well
coming up, it all goes wrong. Radiolab, we'll continue in a moment.
This is Jim Donahue from Fort Worth, Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in a modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
You vote with your dollars when you shop. Well,
what if you could do the same when you invest with swell?
Invest in high growth companies without checking your values at the door.
It's a market opportunity linked to global progress in clean water.
Who are new herbal energy medical breakthroughs.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your accountant's swell.
investing.com/radiolab.
This is Radiolab, uh, with skip back to Simon Adler's story of, uh,
the moment that changed wrestling forever. You'll uh,
you'll also hear Peter Rosenberg from hot 97 in just a moment as well.
He's the first voice we'll hear,
but we'll pick up the action with the on the big match,
the moment we've all been waiting for.
And now Milton Bradley is electronic karate fighters for the 1997 survivors
area.
Okay, here we go. So survivor series of 1997, Montreal
[inaudible]
Oh, the drama. So around nine,
20:00 PM 20,000 people in the stands,
countless television screens across the country. Shawn Michaels come
[inaudible]
he comes out singing his own theme side. I think I'm cute. I know.
Unsexy singing karaoke style. It's prerecorded of him singing.
That's an approach. Yeah, he's got his hair in a ponytail.
He's wearing his trademark black spandex pants,
but hearts all over them like he is the manifestation of everything that Brett
despises. And then outcomes.
Brett Hart waving a Canadian flag
[inaudible]
and he walked into the ring to, gets in, takes off the championship belt,
hands it to the ref. And before the match even officially begin.
Shawn flies it Brett and just start
[inaudible].
John and Brett, they're going at each other.
[inaudible]
it's sort of like real ferocity pretty quick. They're outside the ring.
picks up Shawn,
Chuck's him over the security railing into the from John
[inaudible]. Then there's this moment where Brett picks Shawn up to that.
Sean's legs are straight up in the air and then
rent just slams him on his back.
In. All of this is script.
Yeah. Everything I know about it is like they're following the,
the narrative arc, but like they know, okay,
we're going to fight her out outside the ring for a while and then x, y,
z will happen, and so
eventually Brett throws Sean back into the rain
and then
you get to a point when the match,
which feels very early in the match where Brett climbs onto the turnbuckle,
which is the corner post of the room. He gets up on top of that.
Canada pulls himself off the turnbuckle
Rudy air towards Sean. Mike, Super dramatic.
He's kind of floating in the air there for a moment.
And then [inaudible] hitman.
What Sean does right before bread is about to come and hit him,
he pulls the referee in between Brett and Sean,
a human shield of sorts. Brett hits the referee,
the referee hit Sean and all three men are lying.
Is that a disqualification? It might be if good. I'm Paula.
Oh here we are. Right? This could, this could be the moment, but no,
before the referee can get up. Sean gets up,
walks over to Brett and then look at that. Sean. Oh, you're kidding me.
Brett in the sharp shooter, which is Brett's signature finishing move.
Basically Sean pretzels up bread's legs and sips and within seconds
the bell rings,
Sean Slides out of the rain, grabs the belt, runs to the back, takes off things,
work a certain way in wrestling matches, right? Like no one gets the first pin,
the second match starts and no one puts someone in a submission hold and they
instantly submit,
especially not bred heart and it just did not appear like the time the match was
supposed to end. The crowd is kind of shocked.
It's strangely quiet
and there's this one moment where the camera is zoomed in on Brett's face while
he's lying,
chest down on the mat looking up and there is just this bizarre,
amazing look on his face.
Confusion is an emotion that almost never exists in pro wrestling.
There's the cartoon confusion of like everything's crazy and your arms are going
like wild. Your eyeballs pop out of your head.
The real confusion is one of the most compelling emotions of all.
That's what you see on his face in its most pure form.
Genuine
[inaudible]
and then anger. Brett gets up, puts his arms on the rope,
looks down, sees it, and says man and spits right in Vince's face.
He then proceeds to get out of the ring and basically destroy everything in
sight. He goes over to the announcer's table, starts ripping it apart,
he destroys the monitors, throws the headphones out into the crowd.
He goes pretty nuts
and in maybe the moment that truly made you go, what is happening?
Brett gets back into the ring.
He takes his hand in the air and draws with his finger in the air as big as he
can.
W C W which is where he was going to be leaving to go work w c w and keeps doing
that walking across the range of signaling w c w to the crowd.
[inaudible]
the match. Brett heads back into the locker room looking for a,
let's get up, tells the cameras to shut off.
And then to make a long story short, he clocks Vince in the face,
knocks him out. Now the WWF has a real problem on their hands.
Vince has a black guy and the fourth wall has just been torn down and they need
to figure out how or if they're going to build it back up. And um,
the next day, this again was the head writer at the time, Vince Russo,
we had a television taping right after the, you know, you,
you have roar on Monday, you know, you, you'd do your paper view on Sunday.
You have roar on Monday. So they all huddled in a room to discuss their options.
And Vince says that everybody in that room, that first knee jerk reaction is,
well, we're going to sweep this under the rug and not even talk about it.
I mean that,
that was almost just assumed because you have to understand there's this old
principal in wrestling called [inaudible]
Kayfabe and basically what this is,
is this law of the wrestling God passed down since time eternal that says,
you don't talk about the fact that it's fake.
Everyone knows that it's scripted and that it's fake,
but you damn well better not mention that ever. Why?
Because everybody has a better time when everyone is under the spell of it.
Uh, and I was like, wait a minute,
Vince is walking around with a black eye.
The boys has a black guy and one of the boys punch them in the face.
Russo is saying, I understand Kayfabe but we have to address this.
We can't not acknowledge this. And that doesn't have to be a problem.
That can be an opportunity for us. I mean it like, I hate to say this,
but like it doesn't get any better than this. Rousseau says,
this discussion got very heated.
It was passion filled and in the end nobody really knew what Vince McMahon was
going to do.
Why the time red hearts depth center stays for his match up with Shawn on.
Eventually Vince McMahon decides I'm going to break with Kayfabe.
Now keep in mind he's always been the owner of the organization,
but very few people actually knew that too. Most fans of professional wrestling,
he was just an announcer that night on his own TV show.
He comes out not as Vince McMahon, the ringside announcer,
but as Vince McMahon, the owner of the company.
Let's cut right to the chase seven days ago with the survivor series.
Did you or did you not screw Bret Hart?
Some would say I screwed Bret Harte.
Bret Hart would definitely tell you I screwed them.
I'll look at it from a different standpoint.
I look at it from the standpoint of the referee did not screw Brett Hart.
Sean Michael Certainly did not screw Brett Hart,
nor did Vince McMahon screw bad heart.
I truly believe that Brad Hart screwed Brett Heart.
And you can look in the mirror and know that I'm sure in some parts of the
country right now there's a collective groan that you orchestrated the situation
and the fact that uh,
people are not going to understand what you mean by
Brett Hart Screwed Brett Hart. So what do you mean by that?
There's a time honored tradition in the wrestling business and when someone is
leaving,
they show the right amount of respect to the WWF superstars in this case who
helped make you that superstar you show the proper respect to the organization
that helped you become who you are today.
It's a time honored tradition and Brett Hart didn't want to honor that tradition
and the less that was Brett's decision, Brett
breath and everything changed from that point on.
And according to Peter,
after the Montreal screw job and after this speech,
the writers of the WWF started blurring the lines on a different level.
Vince McMahon, the chairman of the WWE, Ladies and gentlemen. [inaudible],
Mr Nick,
Mr McMann, the character, the number one villain in the company.
Yeah.
There were no more ridiculous, you know, stupid, unbelievable,
childish, ignorant, immature characters.
Every character we had was basically an extension of themselves.
So
you know, stone cold,
Steve Austin was Steve Austin 1000 times magnified.
You know, the Rock was rocky.
My via 100 times magnified.
And as a result,
that was the beginning of the biggest boom in the history of the wrestling
business as far as business goes. This was huge for the WWF and Vince McMahon.
They came roaring back in the ratings war.
They destroyed Ted Turner in the WCW. They won.
And if you ask Vince Russo, why this approach,
this new aesthetic was so successful, he said simply the truth.
That was great TV, plain and simple. The fans just want something true.
Just tell the fans what happened. But Peter says two things.
One, it's way more complicated than that. It's not just about the truth.
You still have these writers who are scripting the show and wrestlers who are
getting that script and following it. So it's not like it's now a true world.
I think it's something more like there are these tiny
injections of truth into this world in really unexpected moments.
What that does is it puts everyone on high alert all the time for those moments
and when everyone is on high alert for those moments all the time,
every moment has the potential to be true,
has the potential to have a little bit of that injection into it and when you
are watching for those injections,
it completely changes how you are engaging with the art form,
with the entertainment and that creates an entirely new type of fan,
what they call a smart fan, a smart mark,
a smart as they're known people who love the wrestling business but really love
the behind the scenes of the business. So what now? What was this smart mark?
Smart Mark. Here's where you can get a little lingo. Crazy.
The lingo part of wrestling is a huge,
huge part of it and a mark is someone who doesn't know that wrestling is fake or
using another piece of jargon here that it is a work. Yes,
a work is anything that's not real as opposed to a shoot,
which is something that's real, like the Montreal screw job. Yes.
Our shoots by definition, something that's not supposed to happen
in the ring. A shoot should never happen.
But then there's something called, of course, a work shoot.
And that's something that does happen. What is that where you, uh,
script it to seem like it's totally unscripted and it may even be real life that
they're injecting into it,
but it with plant was still all discussed that this is what would happen.
And so watching wrestling becomes this game of hunting for the truth according
to David Shoemaker, and not just any truths, but the authentic truth,
the true truths, the true truth. Even if you know that it's fake,
there's some point where the guys are really going at it in the ring that you're
just like, wow, maybe it's real. Just that right there.
And that's what makes wrestling so powerful.
It's the never ending search for the reality within the unreal,
the fact that we get to blend these things together. I mean,
another example that's just is um, in the early two thousands,
there was edge,
Matt hardy and a girl named Lita Lita and Matt Hardy were legitimately in love
dating for years. Edge and Matt Hardy were legitimately best friends
and then
you make your life miserable. Edge ended up with leader.
Took his best friends. Yeah. How do you read, you're like, this will too.
Something that unfortunately happens in life sometimes I thought dob don't mean
guy kills and it was turned into a storyline.
Man had fought over women since the beginning of time and we are hooked up to
see an epic battle over one right now.
I find it incredible that you could go out into the rain
and pretend to beat the hell out of someone.
You want to beat the hell out. To know that you have to go out there,
work really hard against someone you legitimately hate and also absolutely have
to protect. How can we not find that? Fascinating. That's awesome.
That's incredible. It's like watching Fleetwood Mac go on tour. Exactly.
That's what I was going to say next. That's Andrew Morantz by the way,
from the New Yorker and play all their songs cause all their songs.
They all had these love quadrangles.
They all were married and left each other and wrote songs about,
I'm so pissed off at you because you left me for the guy who is standing right
there.
And then they go out on tour and Lindsey Buckingham is standing right next to
Steven x playing the song that he wrote about, you betrayed me.
I hate you so much. It's crazy. It right after night. Super Fascinating. Yeah.
I just think there's a part of the human brain that wants to be confused between
those boundaries that wants to be slipping in between. What's real,
what's fake to feel that confusion.
I feel like that's why Jimmy Fallon was so successful on Saturday night live,
not because he was the greatest sketch comedian, but because he broke a lot.
And you, you can't do that in wrestling because those moments are the best.
You have to save them. You have to save them.
And when people acknowledge a moment and you can tell they look around at the
crowd and they're acknowledging like this is,
or someone says one line that everyone kind of knows is like, Whoa,
that's kind of real. Those moments are special and you have to save them. Yeah.
Hold on one second. I'm sorry. Hey, what's up? He's on the way. All right.
I'll be leaving shortly. Peaceful. Sorry guys. I'll share away. It's,
come on guys. We want a real quick question. What have you, of course,
what happened to Peter, Brent, Brent Hart after this? It's a,
did he go off to WCW and have a big career? Well,
that's sort of the interesting thing is that after the Montreal screw job,
a few weeks later,
Brett showed up on WCW television and it never really worked out for Brett.
In 1999 just two years into his contract with WCW during a match,
he got kicked in the head and suffered a severe concussion
and it, it, it was the beginning of the end that same year.
Well, Ladies and gentlemen, uh, something gone terribly
wrong.
Brett's brother Owen Hartman who was wrestling for the WWF.
Um, during one of his entrances to the match.
He was entering from the ceiling and something with the stunt went terribly
wrong and he fell 50 feet into the ring and he died.
Anything, this is not a part of the show. This is real life.
Oh one mark is being attended to right now by host. I went through,
I right away. I said, I could never, I don't think I can ever go back.
Brett Hart spoke with Terry Gross about a year after this incident.
You think of all these sort of contrived storylines that they have in wrestling.
You know,
this guy's going to come in and he's going to do that and he's going to,
he's going to say this about you or they're going to, I just thought I heard.
Anything you can possibly imagine is so pathetically meaningless when you relate
to the, the real life horror. What happened with my brother,
he would retire shortly after saying that.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so thank you to, um, to Simon. Uh, what did we decide?
His wrestling name was Simon Simon, the growling gruyere. Adler Adler.
It says he's from Wisconsin,
so you have to be like a fierce cheese cheese and thank you also as a very
special thanks to fresh air for letting US air their Brett Hart interview and
thank you also to Paul Jay for allowing us to play some clips from his
documentary wrestling with shadows.
[inaudible]
your opponent fight.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab will continue in a moment. Yeah.
Here it's Peter Rosenberg and I'm going to try to do my best to do this.
Radiolab is supported part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org Radiolab is produced by W N Y C and
distributed by NPR. Hope that works later guys. Bye.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
What if you could invest in our planet while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies working towards clean water,
renewable energy, and green technology. It's a market opportunity.
You can feel good about. Get a $50 bonus when you open your account at swell,
investing.com/radiolab
we're back. Luke, tell us who you are.
I am Bruce Burningham and where do you teach?
I teach at Illinois State University. This is Radiolab. I'm Jad. I'm Robert.
So Bruce, he's a a scholar,
a language professor and I called him up because Jared and I were having a
little disagreement, friendly one. Okay. We're having an argument here.
I said that when you get to hip hop and the wrestling and the novels and all
that, you're getting a sort of a a moment,
contemporary moment where people are fascinated by authenticity.
And then Jad my partner says, I don't know,
maybe people have always been interested in authenticity and this is just comes
with being a human. It's nothing about now, it just about us. I mean that's,
that's,
it's new in the sense that this generation of which we belong has become very
interested in these kinds of questions. But Bruce told me this preoccupation,
it's not really new. In fact, at least in book form,
it goes back way longer than you think. 1605 well,
before wrestling and before Fleetwood Mac and before Jimmy Fallon began laughing
at his own jokes, there was Miguel Servon, his book. Don Quixote. Yeah.
So the first book really is about authenticity from like from the get go,
you opened this book Don Quixote by Miguel de Cervantes.
And right away the narrator says,
I'm going to tell you a story which I actually gathered from other authors from
a bunch of different historical documents. So I'm not really the author.
He says things like, well, some books say the first adventure was this,
and some say it was that. So even from the start,
you have a very unreliable narrator who then proceeds to tell the story of a
very unreliable, if not completely crazy, he character don Quixote,
who is dry with capricious and filled with in constant thoughts.
Never imagined about anyone else.
So Don Quixote believes that he has been set on earth to rescue widows,
Princesses, and pee and be kind to orphans. He's like a delusional,
totally delusion. He is. He's essentially a WHO's, who's
read too many Zane Gray novels and decides he needs to be a cowboy.
He thinks herds of sheep are attacking armies.
He thinks windmills are giants at the same time, he has this savvy assistant,
central Ponsa who seems to know what's really going on.
And they're constantly arguing about what's real and what's not.
And then in chapter eight, something really strange happens one day,
Don Quixote and Sandra Panzer are traveling down the road and they see a
carriage with a woman inside. Just an ordinary woman going, you know,
to meet her husband, Donkey Hook. Hey, whatever, for no reason at all, uh,
decides that she is a woman in distress, needs to be rescued.
And he spies this man standing right next to the carriage. He's,
he's [inaudible]
Basque guy sees this guy and he decides that he's a,
he's an enemy who needs to be confronted. And so they start fighting.
Don't get caught. They was charging the wary, bask with his sword on high,
determined to cut him in half and the Basque was waiting for him.
He sword also raised and in mid swing when both swords are in the air,
the narrator's stops and says, and I don't know where this goes from there,
I've run out of material and you just sort of stop scenario and this is what?
16 oh something 1605 stops. Just stopping.
That's the end of the book. Well No.
So you turn the page and you're in a new chapter and now the narrators is
telling you how as luck would have it,
he found this manuscript one day when I was in the [inaudible] market in Toledo.
Crazily enough, he's out of bizarre, I guess,
sort of a shopping kind of place and he sees this pile of old papers and books
together in a basket and he's just rifling through it and he sees a picture of
Don [inaudible].
I was astounded and filled with anticipation. Very Paz,
apparently I real historical account in which the stupendous battle between the
gun and busk and the Valeant man chicken is concluded.
The problem was it was in Arabic and so then he hires a local Maurisco who is a
Christianized more to translate it for him. All right,
so you now got a guy who's writing a book from historical sources.
He's run out of one, he's found another,
but now that one has to be translated and on top of that you frequently inserts
commentary about the translation and we'll say stuff like, well,
CDM met day says this, but we all know that Arabs can't be trusted. So you know,
take that for what that's worth.
How does, I'm reading it. I'm thinking, wait a second.
This was written in 1605 what did people make of a book that didn't seem to have
any author had author upon author upon author, like were they horror?
What the book was a bestseller. It was hugely popular.
Apparently people found all these layers and these ambiguity's a laugh riot.
Oh yeah. They gobbled up and they left as hard as they could.
This is Howard Manson, a savant.
These scholar at Purdue and doe Chiota was translated into English and 1612 into
French in 1614 into Italian in 1622 everybody read it,
including in the new world by the way,
many copies of the first edition of donkey hilltoppers were shipped to the
colonies. Wow. So the book is a wide bestseller,
maybe the first of its kind and then 10 years later, 10 years later,
sort of Andres writes a sequel,
which kicks up this narrative weirdness to a completely new level in part two to
don Quixote of Lamont. He introduces a new character named Samson Carrasco.
He actually visits Donkey Hill Day in sand show to tell them that part one
exists. It's a bestseller.
And so in the very early chapters of part two donkey,
how this would be like walking up to huckleberry Finn says, oh, by the way,
you're living here in Hannibal, Missouri, but you're now a famous boy.
That's exactly what happened. Everybody he meets,
knows who he is because they've read part one and now it gets even stranger.
Because in real life,
during that 10 years that it took surveys to write his second book,
a person who goes by the pseudonym of Alonzo Fernandez,
they have of [inaudible] published his own second part of donkey. They,
before Serantes could get his own second part out. Wait, so this is,
this is an unofficial part two today. We'd recognize it as,
as sort of fanfiction or,
or somebody attempting to steal George Lucas's idea and come up with their own
star wars installment. So there's this unauthorized part to floating around.
Miguel survived days is very annoyed by it, I'm assuming.
So in his official sequel to Don Quixote,
there is this scene where Don Quixote is at an inn and he overhears a character
talking about his relationship with, with this, suppose that donkey hood.
They wait. So this guy,
this guy that Simon Adler who sat in on the interview with me,
this guy existed in the fake Quixote.
Number two is a character in that, in is now appearing in the real [inaudible].
Number two Serantes serantes steals him. If you're gonna steal my character,
I'll steal yours back. Right? So now you've got the real donkey. Okay,
he's bumping into a character stolen from a fake book of donkey owed,
so, so why don't you to, it then decides to confront this person.
He marches right up to the guy and he says,
I am.
Don't go to have Lamont Cha the same one who is on the lips of fame and not that
unfortunate men who has water to use [inaudible] my name and bring honor to
himself with my thoughts. And so it, and it's the climax of that scene,
which is just wonderful, is he?
He forces this other character who he stolen from the unauthorized SQL who
serantes has stolen to admit that the donkey haute that he knows from the
unauthorized sequel is not the real one.
And that the one he's currently talking to is the real one. I am coolio.
Grace for the sake of what you owe to your being a gentlemen to please make a
statement to the magistrate of this village. And as a matter of fact, he,
he forces him to sign an affidavit to that effect. Perfect.
Okay, so he busts him, he busts him right in the novel, in the novel.
But you've got a story about a guy that then becomes in part to a story about
the story about the guy including false guys inside the story about the false
guys from another book. That right here.
So why even bother trying to out what's real. Right.
Has anything like this come before?
No.
He's really sort of inventing this whole meta-narrative game that that is so
popular today that you met a narrative. What, what of, well up until that point,
most stories are simply, they purport to be what they are.
I'm telling you a story, but donkey haute,
they pretends to be something other than what it is.
It really is the start of modernity, our modern sense of the world.
So you'll get with Jad Ben, and this is like this.
This is not co Waxton Wayne this particular year or cause I think, well,
it has what? It has waxed and waned.
I mean th Don Quixote has been read by different generations for different
reasons.
Bruce says he thinks the people who were reading the book originally at the time
have survived this. They actually reveled in, in the multilevels of fiction.
They loved the metastatic during the romantic period and and well into the early
20th century.
People were less interested in all these narrative layers and they were more
just in thrilled by the romantic dunk EOD or the dream or Don Quixote.
This generation of which we belong has become very interested in this terrain
that serantes charted a long time ago.
You see it in the cinema of the late nineties in movies like the Matrix.
Then later adaptation of an inception or exploring the concept of the dream
within a dream.
See it in Seinfeld, what's going on,
what we're going to shoot the pilot and then it's going to be on TV to follow.
Anyway. Yeah, no,
there's this Canadian Jerry Seinfeld who's playing a character that happens to
be called Jerry Seinfeld,
who's making a show within the show about a character who's,
who's Jerry Seinfeld.
And so you have reality nested three times.
But I guess I'm interested in this idea of why is,
how is this happening again and why is it happening again? Well,
my sense of things is that both of these moments are moments of intellectual
crisis back in servant. This time coming out of the renaissance,
you have all of this new scientific knowledge that is calling into question the
foundation that everybody was building their lives on.
So suddenly the earth is no longer the center of the universe.
It's now just one planet amongst several orbiting the sun.
So you have people coming to terms with a worldview that they can no longer
sustain. And as for us now, in the last hundred years, you have Darwinism,
you have relativity, you have quantum physics.
I mean cognitive scientists are telling us that we have no free will because
they can sort of chart the chemical reaction that happens milliseconds before
we, we think we decided to do something.
All of these things tell us that the world that we think we see is not what it
is. And I think that inspires people to then start asking these questions. If,
if what I'm seeing is not real, what is, who am I?
And so I think to a great extent it's,
it's a reaction to a moment of intellectual crisis. Wait, but okay,
let's say that I liked professional wrestling a lot.
I don't know anything about any of the research you're telling me about why the
hell do I like professional wrestling and why did I like it more when they
started blurring these lines? Hard question.
Well, I would say humans are humans and one of the things that we do is,
is as opposed to as far as we know,
what other animals on this planet do is we are aware of our own contingency.
Meaning we can imagine radically different possibilities.
We could imagine worlds where we don't exist or maybe we only think we exist.
I can remember being a child four and five years old and going to a fabric store
with my mother.
And there were two mirrors set against opposite walls and I was just fascinated
at standing in between them and watching the infinite regress go in each
direction. Um, you know, and I, I had not even started kindergarten yet.
So I think,
I think humans have this fascination with infinite regress and with embeddedness
and with the questions that it forces you to consider,
like where does everything begin and where does it all come from? I mean,
the question at the heart of Donkey Haute,
they realizing that he's a character in a novel is who stands above you.
The author stands above you.
And so that author has a kind of godlike relationship to you,
but that very question starts to make you ask who stands above that author?
And if you start asking that question, it goes on forever and every direction.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] thank you to Rupert Boyd for coming and playing the Spanish guitar
for us.
[inaudible] on very short notice and two recorded books for giving us permission
to use George Greenhouses. Wonderful read of the book.
Thank God that I'm on a journey. He's really good. Okay, well,
I guess we should go then. We should say you should go goodbye. Say Goodbye.